you like virtual reality I love it
do you want to live there yeah
yeah
part of me does too
how far away are we do you think
judging from what you can buy today far
very far
I gotta tell you that I had the
experience of
uh meta's Kodak Avatar where it's a
ultra high resolution scan
it looked real
I mean the headsets just are not quite
at like I resolution yet
I haven't put on any headset where I'm
like oh I this could be the real world
whereas when I put good headphones on
audio is there I think we we can
reproduce audio that I'm like I'm
actually in a jungle right now I I if I
close my eyes I can't tell I'm not
yeah but then there's also smell and all
that kind of stuff sure
I don't know I
the power of imagination or the power of
the the mechanism in the human mind that
fills the gaps that kind of reaches and
wants to make the thing you see in the
virtual world real to you
I believe in that power or humans want
to believe yeah
like what if you're lonely what if
you're sad what if you're really
struggling in life and here's a world
where you don't have to struggle anymore
humans want to believe so much that
people think the large language models
are conscious that's how much humans
want to believe
strong Wars he's throwing left and right
hooks